it's about doing the best show that you
can do and it's about staying at the
edge I want to do a better show every
time I'm on stage and part of it is that
I want what I do to keep getting better
I think a lot of people in show business
in comedy especially are very lazy and
they just sort of think that you just
get up there and then you wait for your
manager to get you a better one it's a
little better shot but it's it's
something you got to really want to keep
working at it I wouldn't like it if I
stopped trying really hard it isn't a
neurosis like oh geez I hope they like
me it's this is what I do I got to do it
really really well I grew up on a kids
and started really thinking about Stan
when I had kids it made a big difference
for me because when I went out to do was
set it wasn't a social event it was
until that point you just go to the
Comedy Cellar have a falafel at the
comedy table yeah run down and do your
set [ __ ] with some comics it was a
lot of wasting time yeah and it didn't
really matter how the set was that was
just the job I'm just gonna go on and do
my time tell the same jokes maybe do one
new joke but now it's like I've got kids
and getting out of the house is a big
deal yeah do a set tonight and I ain't
wasting any time I got a list of stuff I
want to try I want to make sure that
this set makes me better I started to
think every set I do has to make me
better comic you just watched two
amazing clips from louis c.k take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]